the question right now is why can't i
just get in gear i want to bring in
bitcoin expert leia helpern and leo you
know first i want to give you props
because the last time you were on or
maybe two times ago you talked about the
people of ukraine and you touted the way
bitcoin was being used to help them
during this crisis after that that's the
only thing i saw with people talking
about this the situation obviously is
escalated give us an update on that for
us
yeah absolutely it's a really
fascinating situation um i think we saw
um the government in ukraine actually
offering several different bitcoin
wallets well not just bitcoin but
ethereum um usdt which is a stablecoin
peg to the us dollar i think even dot
they were offering um so really this is
the first time we're ever seeing
something like this and i think it's
really fascinating because we're finally
seeing bitcoin on the world stage as
that humanitarian money rather than this
typical sort of you know criminal idea
which is always portrayed in the media
so uh you know a lot of tweets over the
weekend got my attention one though i
wanted to share with you uh came from
scott galloway and he essentially said
i'm doubling down on the most innovative
payment technology and store value the
u.s dollar so i had to get your thoughts
on that because essentially he's saying
forget about gold and forget about
bitcoin nothing could beat the greenback
your thoughts
yeah i think you know that's a very
old-fashioned mentality unfortunately
and i think we have to give people time
to start to see bitcoin's fundamental
value bitcoin's fundamental value is
being decentralized being immune from
government corruption being censorship
resistant and only time will allow
people to start to see this we need to
give time we need to allow the
geopolitical landscape to continue to
evolve and only then will people start
to see bitcoin on the world stage i mean
it is only 13 years old and if you even
look at what's happened over the last 13
years you could argue that really over
only in the last two years during covert
have we started to see bitcoin's
fundamental value as that hedge against
inflation and you could even go further
and argue that only in the last two
months at the beginning of 2022 have we
started to really see bitcoin and its
underlying technology and the
fundamental value as that censorship
resisted money so i think with time
tweaks like that will start to become
less and less and time will essentially
put bitcoin on the world stage and make
people wake up and realize what the use
case really is speaking of use case and
i got 30 seconds there's still this
debate over a store value a currency uh
part of the defy you know blockchain i
mean what's the central selling point
because it feels like it's spinning its
wills right now as a ton of money is
going into gold in other areas
yeah i mean i'm not surprised that money
is going into gold because it's still
got that you know that name as the
traditional safe haven asset people like
to hold something physical it's really
you know stood the test of time um but
you know and of course yeah it has to
the test of time it's been through one
war two wars three wars you know
centuries bitcoin is only 13 years old
so i'm not surprised but i think people
do just need to be patient and wait and
allow it to prove itself on the world
stage with time we'll do that leah thank
you very much folks we'll be right back